was ist warum um gottes sind guckt euch
mal das und mein gott es tut mir echt
leid diese schalen hast du umbindet nein
natürlich meint ich finde jetzt was um
ich dachte ich darf mir es aussuchen
da darfst du aber nicht so das ist eine
hose ok also alles klar
ich wollte etwas sehen nein das tut mir
weh ich habe das gut das gut aber okay
leute ganz kurz für euch zur erklärung
ich habe hier eine seite aufgerufen ja
genau gesehen wir sind kann auch auf
youtube die hat mache ich noch nicht
gesehen und zwar waren wir letztes jahr
wir waren letztes jahr um diese zeit in
griechenland
genauer gesagt auf santorini und dieses
jahr wollten wir wieder nach
griechenland und ich habe jetzt eine
challenge überlegt weil wir uns einfach
nicht einig geworden sind wo wir
hinfahren und deswegen darfst du jetzt
blind also deswegen hast du dieses ding
hier sind jetzt alle ziele von den
inseln und du musst jetzt eine aussuchen
und dann gucken wir ob wir dann auch
schon das hotel ob das auch blind bist
oder dass vielleicht nicht weiß wie das
geht es nur um das reiseziel du das
jetzt entscheiden wo es hingeht blind
hier sind alle inseln und ich wünsche
ganz viel spaß
ok also jetzt ihm aus ich halte das
hierzu meinetwegen so jetzt kann ich
jetzt einfach irgendwo drauf ja
jetzt hast du genau nichts getroffen
das war eng aber schon wieder nix auch
nichts auch nicht auch nichts sagt man
immer diese felder und warte ich mache
sie mit dem man hier so jetzt jetzt
jetzt sagst du die maus nicht mal so
weit bewegen
du bist gerade auch werbung und das
musst du irgendwo bewegt die einfachen
wohin also der partie doch jetzt hab ich
ja noch gar nichts sagt theoretisch
könntest du jetzt klicken und dann
hätten wir ein ziel
theoretisch klingt ja da muss doch mal
kriegen weil er das nicht erkannt wer
weiß schon ob willst du willst bist du
dir sicher dass du jetzt klicken willst
dass du kein zurück mehr
also wir ziehen hast du 100 prozent
durch ich nehme auch nichts anderes wenn
du dann unzufrieden bis tempo und 321
bitte ok also ich muss halt ich muss
sagen das war meine zweite das war meine
zwei favorisiertes hatte was glaubst du
ist es was kurs und da muss ich noch mal
grob kurs
bist du bereit 3 2 1 alex hat mir
richtig die augenhöhlen rein gedrückt
was sagst du dazu ist eigentlich gut
oder ja also ich mach das jetzt so
hubmann können wir auch spazierengehen
und danke jetzt bald schon los das seht
ihr in den blog also wir haben das jetzt
noch ein bisschen vorher aufgenommen
aber ich hoffe ich finde was cool ist
das zeige ich euch auch einen blog
weil ich wollte euch kurz noch zeigen
wir haben uns diesmal für einen hotel
entschieden was irgendwie echt sehr
preiswert ist meiner meinung nach also
man zahlt hierfür eine woche zwei
personen 790 euro ist voll in ordnung
und ich bin auch mal gespannt ob es denn
nicht so aussieht wie auf diesen bildern
hier die flüge haben ungefähr 350 euro
gekostet also die wollen jetzt nicht so
günstig aber man kann sich glaube ich
für eine woche da nicht beschweren wenn
sogar frühstück mit drin
leute leider habe ich mir eine kamera
nicht aufgeladen das heißt ich konnte so
ein bisschen im handy mit filmen so hat
auf jeden fall die reise angefangen
[Musik]
zumal wir sind jetzt mit flugzeug und
jetzt irgendwo im ausgang gesundheit
card guard so leute und damit herzlich
willkommen aus rhodos
ja sie habe ja schon gesehen wo es
hingeht oder wo es hingehen sollte wir
sind jetzt dass der zweite tag gestern
habe ich ausnahmsweise mal nicht gefilmt
wir sind hier im ich weiß gar nicht
genau wie das total heißt irgendwie erst
berio village oder so ich muss sagen der
blick ihr seht ja ist wirklich genial da
unten ist irgendeine straße was ich
nicht so schön finden hier sind halt
überall diese fetten hotels umgebaut das
macht die insel voll kaputt so wir sind
hier so inso appartementanlagen die so
den berg hoch gebaut sind halt nicht so
fette betonklötze so das finde ich noch
schön aber wenn ich mir das angucken ich
weiß ist natürlich auch nicht schlimm
aber irgendwie ist das so dass trauriger
im ausblick
naja damit ihr auch was vom blog habt
würde ich sagen wir haben uns heute ein
auto gemietet und wir kunden bisschen
die insel unternehme ich euch mal mit
oder wie ihr euch und mal schauen was
für schöne ecken wir hier finden werden
was sagst du denn so zu insel wird er
gleich in einem preview ist halt auch
sehr sehr deutsch lasst ich will es mal
so ja stimmt hier sind wir sind ehrlich
fast nur deutsche ich komme mir vor wie
auch mal oder
so aber von der insel her finde es
richtig schön liste der grünen natur und
das geld gleich sehen wir jetzt gleich
konnten dieselben leute anwesend wäre
ich nur deutsche rentner die alle den
ganzen tag bier trinken und am strand
liegen jetzt schauen wir mal was nettes
auto ausleihen können ganz schön warm
heute für die die es interessiert wir
haben heute 27 grad
[Musik]
weil das mein job
so leute wir haben uns ein auto
ausgeliehen wir haben netterweise sogar
einen tipp bekommen eigentlich kriegt
man den erst wenn man ein gewisses alter
hut aber irgendwie habe ich den müll hat
und dann hat es geklappt ist auf jeden
fall ein richtig geiles auto bin ich
noch nie gefahren man sitzt ultra hoch
und wir sind jetzt gerade bei windows
also wir sind ja hier auf rhodos und
windows ist irgendwie so diese diese so
einem film die stadt ist schon 5000
jahre alt und das soll so die schönste
stadt hier sein was ich sehr schade
finde hier gibt es überall so bei ihnen
auch hier hinter uns warte mal was ist
warum das ist mein gott oh mein gott das
sind einfach tote schafe
guckt euch mal das und mein gott es tut
mir echt leid ich dachte gerade dass wir
so vom bau weiter da sind einfach ja man
hier gehe ich nicht ein alter da sieht
man mal wie hier anscheinend die tiere
zum teil gehalten werden war das echt
krass kummer die sind einfach verhungert
oder was weiß ich nicht dachte gerade
erst das wir also vom bauschutt so
besser so leute wir sind hier gerade in
windows keine ahnung vielleicht waren
hier einige von euch gemacht das ist so
alles so typisch griechisch zu enge
gassen ist ganz nett aber auch extrem
heiß
jetzt wollen wir eigentlich erst mal
schwimmen oder leute hier kann man noch
mal ganz anders sehen ich bin also von
oben sieht auf jeden fall echt geil aus
da ist auch noch so eine burg ja und wir
gehen jetzt aber erstmal da irgendwie
schwimmen also ich muss wirklich sagen
an der ecke wo wir sind da sind halt
überall und diese ganzen hotel
aber wenn man hier mal so herunter guckt
also das ist schon geil leute da unten
zudem bieten wird
das wasser ist echt mega heiß das wasser
ist echt geil so leute das war's auch
schon mit dem baden ich habe irgendwie
gar keine aufnahmen machen können weil
ich habe die gopro vergessen system blöd
aber ihr seht es noch mal das wasser war
wirklich extrem lies und jetzt geht es
weiter wir haben dieses coole autos
fahren jetzt mal so ein bisschen ins
landesinnere
ich hoffe ihr könnt mich gerade
verstehen kann sein dass bisschen windig
ist dann schauen wir mal wo wir gleich
landen leute wenn wir jetzt schon so ein
geiles auto haben muss man ja auch
eigentlich mal so ein cooles fotos
schießen
deswegen steigt auf jeden fall mal ab
instagram alex wie und marie beides hier
eingeblendet
[Musik]
ich habe ja schon abgerissen
so leute wir sind jetzt schon wieder
davon unserem tagesausflug und ich habe
mich schon heute wieder fertig gemacht
wir gehen uns was essen
ich wollte einfach mal kurz hier unser
appartement zeigen oder das hotelzimmer
wie es aussieht dann kommt hier also
rein hat hier überall getränke sind ja
bis jetzt nichts besonderes das hier ist
das badezimmer haben wir einmal die
dusche also mit badewanne klo fenster
ich noch irgendwas interessantes ich
glaube nicht dann geht man hier halt
raus
das hat hier das bett ist ein super
bequem ins bett eigentlich wären sehr
schminkspiegel speziell ganz ganz
wichtig für mich
hier schlafen wir noch unsere kinder
also zwei kinderbetten unsere kinder
also der hier ist ungefähr den habe ich
jetzt schon so zwei jahre und den hier
keine ahnung habe ich so vor einem jahr
zugeschickt bekommt ja ja genau genau
und das hier ist der balkon
wir gehen jetzt was essen also ist
gleich das hier ist übrigens diese ganze
anlage das ist so voll auf diesem berg
gebaut da oben sind noch viel mehr
appartements also ist eigentlich echt
cool gemacht den ich persönlich halt
viel besser als die fetten betonklötze
hotels die da unten den ganzen strand
versauen
die senioren hinter uns gespenst gerade
darüber dass die animation im hotel
nicht gut ist also der ausblick von hier
oben ist echt geil
nur diese fetten hotel kürze da das
finde ich das zerstört irgendwie alles
oder oder was sagst du dazu wollen wir
da hingehen und sagen wir finden das
echt blöd und eigentlich was wir haben
jetzt den nächsten tag ich wollte
eigentlich das video schon verendet
aber eine sache die dies die muss ich
noch kurz erzählen und zwar waren wir
gestern im hotel restaurant essen und
ich habe so eine katze gestreichelt und
die hat mich gekratzt also vielleicht
kann man es hier sehen hier ist ein
kratzer und der kellner hat das halt
gesehen und hier sind halt auch so wilde
katzen und so und ich sage ja wegen
bakterien und also ins zeug und der hat
uns dann halt so desinfektions
beigegeben und die haben sich das total
sorgen gemacht und wollten noch so den
arzt rufen und so und ich habe gesagt
nein alles gut da passiert schon nichts
will auch geimpft und sodann haben
gestern muss man dazu sagen
die getränke auslaufen kann nachher dann
gab es erstmal die getränke aus dem
hotelmanager ja das auch noch und jetzt
kommt ein noch so so was ist das hier
ein lecker mag ich sehr gerne nicht also
tipp an euch
wenn es im urlaub mal nicht so läuft das
tier einfach kurz von der katze kratzen
so ein kleiner kratzer und dann kriegt
man einige vorteile aber der obstteller
ist doch ganz nah ist oder aber was man
wirklich sagen muss das hotel ist super
die kümmern sich hier richtig gemein
machen sich anscheinend auch sehr sorgen
deswegen ja schon raus an
display village in bludenz war oder so
ich schreibe euch den namen der germanen
die beschreibung ist ein ice hotel das
war's mit dem blog ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen lassen doch nach oben da schaut
bei instagram vorbei und wir gehen jetzt
gleich schwimmen haut rein